50,000 "Witcher" fans can't be wrong.
Or can they?
Here's how some of the show's most loyal watchers
are trying to keep the dream of a Henry Cavill-led "Witcher" alive.
Fans of Netflix's "The Witcher" are still
reeling from the recent news that Cavill will
no longer be donning his iconic white wig
after Season 3.
"Enjoy your last walk across the meadow, and
through the mist."
Cavill has officially laid down his swords
as Geralt of Rivia and will instead be picking
up that iconic red cape once again.
Some have speculated that the actor's departure
from the Netflix series was due to incompatible
work schedules.
Without a doubt, fighting crime and the forces
of evil as Superman is an intensive and time-consuming
position to be in.
Not to mention that, in all likelihood, being
part of the DC Universe pays better than acting
on "The Witcher."
However, many fans aren't too happy that Cavill
won't be returning to the role, and will be
replaced by Australian actor (and brother
to Thor) Liam Hemsworth.
Out of all this discontentment, a Change.org
petition emerged, similar to what happened
after "Game of Thrones" Season 8 aired.
The petition titled "NETFLIX: You MUST keep
Henry Cavill as The Witcher and replace the
writers instead" has blown up, and, as of
the making of this video, it has nearly reached
its goal of 50,000 signatures.
Stef Ma, the creator of the petition, wrote,
in part,
"Let us show them in pure numbers [...] that
none of us Witcher fans will stand with them
and will abandon the show (and potentially
our subscriptions) after The Witcher season
3 is concluded."
Unfortunately, this puts Liam Hemsworth, who
can’t be blamed for the recasting, in an
unfavorable position.
On an Instagram post, the Australian actor
acknowledged that Cavill handed him the reins
of the series' beloved protagonist, and while
some commenters showed their support, many
others expressed their displeasure.
One of the top comments with over 5,000 likes
reads, "no. stop.
you can't replace henry"
"Witcher" fans have been quite vocal about
their opposition to the major change all over
the internet.
On Reddit, there are multiple threads about
the recasting.
One user wrote,
"Well, there goes the single redeeming factor
of the show."
This got several replies, including,
"I actually really like Joey Batey [...] The
bard song is cool, and his character is slowly
developing rather nicely.
But yeah, other than that, you're totally
right."
"I'm going to drink.
I am not having this conversation unless I'm
drinking."
Indeed, one should not discredit the other
actors who have also fully dedicated themselves
to the series like Batey, Anya Chalotra, and
Freya Allan.
However, together they don’t seem to be
enough to relieve fans' doubts regarding the
future of the series.
During his three seasons on "The Witcher,"
Henry Cavill seemed born to play Geralt of Rivia.
This was, in great part, thanks to the incredible
passion Cavill nurtured for the fantasy franchise,
first as a fan of the video games and later
as a fan of Andrzej Sapkowski's novels.
In an interview with Graham Norton, Cavill
was asked whether he knew more than anyone
else on set.
Ever humble, Cavill denied knowing more than
anyone else and just called himself a "big fan."
Norton then asked whether he corrected others
on set, to which Cavill replied that he doesn't,
adding,
"I am effusive about getting, about being
loyal to the source material, let's put it that way."
Those are the operative words: "loyal to the
source material."
It has somewhat become common knowledge even
among those who haven't read the books that
the Netflix show, especially after the first
season, strayed from Sapkowski's original story.
Although Cavill has never outright said it,
his comments to Norton suggest that he might
not have been content with the direction the
series had taken, ultimately leading to him
stepping down as the monster hunter.